بما اننا نشهد موسم كاس العالم هذه الايام
نشاهد مباريات كره القدم كل يوم بات الحظر
واجب هذه راس المانيه حديثه كشفت ان
مشاهده مباريات كره القدم تمتلك تاثيرا
سلبيا على القلب ونصحت بالتخفيف من الحماس
المبالغه
للدراسه فانه مشاهده الاحداث الرياضيه قد
تؤثر على القلب والاوعيه عن طريق رفع
مستويات التوتر العاطفي الاضافه الى زياده
ضغط الدم ومعدل ضربات القلب بشكل ملحوظ
الباحثون لاحظوا ان المشاركين في الدراسه
عنه من ارتفاع ضغط الدم وصلوا الى معدلات
مرتفعه من ضربات القلب والى مستويات خطيره
ايضا خلال مباريات الحاسمه كما بقيت
القراءات عاليه لعده ساعات بعد المباراه
كما تبين ان الاثاره الناتجه عن اللعبه
تؤدي الى زياده مستويات هرمون الاجهاد هذه
النتائج السابقه التي ابهرت ان الضغط
الناجم عن مشاهده وتشجيع فرق كره القدم
اثناء المنافسات الكبيره يمكن ان يكون
اثار قصيره
طبعا المباراه بتشد الاعصاب قوي يعني
فدرجه التعصب بتكون عاليه جدا يعني ممكن
تتعامل بكل حواسك
بحركات في اليد كده يعني
وبحب الكره من زمان
التعصب الكروي الحماس الزائد يقول الى
مشاكل صحيه ونفسيه خطيره قد تكون ما رايكم
بذلك دكتور
كلامك صحيح هذه الدراسه ليست جديده طبعا
كانت دراسه سابقه اشارت لهذا الشيء وكانت
اصلا على الجمهور الامريكي في لعبه كره
القدم الامريكيه واكتشفوا انه كميه الضغط
والتوتر للتحدث قبل المباريات واثناء
المباريات وبعد المباريات تسبب ارتفاع
شديد في التوتر العام وضغط في الجسم نتيجه
افراز نوعي من الهرمونات الادرينالين اللي
يؤثر على عضله القلب وعلى كل الجهاز
العصبي لكن الاكثر خطوره بنظري انا هو
هرمون الكورتيزون اللي كل انواع الخلايا
في الجسم وهو الهرمون المسؤول عن البقاء
واستمرار الخليه لذلك الدراسات اثبت انه
الناس المتعصبين بكل الاشياء اعمارهم
قصيره جدا
اسامه هل التعصب يعني الذي يعاني من
التعصب الكروي هو متعصب في كل شيء في
الحياه شديد الغضب على اي امر ولا لا يمكن
المقارنه بين الامرين بعض المراكز البحثيه
اعاده التعصب الرياضي الى التعلق المرضي
وقالت انه بعض الاشخاص يبحثوا عن اي
انتصارات حتى يثبته انهم افضل من الاخرين
بل ان بعضهم اعادها الى العنف الدفين داخل
الانسان اللي كذبته الاديان والمجتمعات
والقوانين لكن كان هذا المتنفس الوحيد
امامهم ان يعلن تفوقهم على الاخرين هل
الانسان المتعصب رياضيا المتعصب في اشياء
اخر همم من خبرتي الشخصيه مع بعض الاشخاص
اللي يكرهوني بصداقتهم اكتشفت انه الناس
المتعلقين جدا باشياء رياضيه معظم الاحيان
من الصعب النقاش معهم في اشياء اخرى